Let's talk about the artists today.
Right. A lot of artists that are out,
new, new ones that are a part of our
generation that have grown.
What is your mindset with the state of
rap now?
I think it's fire.
It's a whole different.
Ball game, you know what I mean?
Like, like whole different crop of
young superstars and styles, you know
what I mean? Um, I think to me, the the
I've been feeling like this for like,
maybe a year or two.
It's like. I hate to say it almost
because it sounds like almost like
pandering, but I really do think like,
man. It's a lot of fire female rappers.
And it's like, I feel like they're.
Doing sound like pandering. Yeah, I.
Feel like they're doing some of the most
exciting commercially.
They're doing some of the most
exciting. They're giving us a lot of
fire moments, you know what I mean?
And I feel like that's something that
wasn't around when the.
Volume was never.
It was never like that. You always had a
one, a Lil Kim, you had a 5G.
But it was always.
It was always one. It can never be more
than one almost. It felt like now it's
like, bro, we're getting moments and
moments and moments. I think that's
hard.
It's dope to hear you say that, too.
I mean, you know, I know that there's a
conversation, of course, attached to
female rappers from female rappers of
just like wanting the support from
many. And there's a thing of like,
well, you know, we are saying the same
things that men are saying.
We don't want the feedback or, you
know, to to receive backlash.
At the end of the day, we're embracing
the craft. So to hear you embrace what
they're doing, I know probably means
the world to them. And honestly, just
to be current and see that like that's
something that not being in the
business that I see.
What about male Where are you at with
the, the, the males that are out there?
It's hard. It's f***ing a good time.
And are you in?
I guess you could say. Are you in a
space where you have acted as a voice
mentoring? Are you available?
Not I'm avail-- I'm available.
Like I made the decision like maybe I
don't know. I don't know how long ago
it was now, but it was some years ago
where I was like, because when I came
in I was very much like I was so
competitive. It was like everything
was. Close quarter.
I'm like, We're not friends.
So it's like, you know what I mean? I'm
not going to sit here and fake it, but
boom, I was I was very much on my own
trying to get to where I was trying to
go. And I realized I was like, oh, I
turned around. I was like, oh, wait.
Like, because I started thinking about.
The end, I started thinking about a day
when it's like, bruh. Like, I love
doing this now, but I don't know if I
want to. I don't know if I want to be
doing this forever, you know what I
mean? So the thought of the of an
ending started coming in my mind.
So then the thought was, yo, if you, if
you, if you were to end and this was to
be your last album, this would be your
last album. Like what?
Who did you work with?
Who did you form a bond with?
Who did you have a lasting memory with?
And that, like kind of woke me up where
it was like, Bro, you like, you've been
too closed off. So I purposely just
started opening myself up.
So when when I meet somebody, you could
have just came out, boom, boom.
I meet with you. We have a good
conversation, bro. Take my line. Boom,
boom, boom. Hit me.
So it's like I've been that person way
more over the past few years.
Yo, take my line, hit me, reach out.
So I've had great moments with artists
. And
up and coming. I mean, it was dope.
There was something that I think is the
it's the small things that become the
biggest, right? That show that you're
in tune. More importantly, with
understanding the hustle, understanding
what an opportunity looks and feels
like, and sometimes being a part of
that springboard launch pad or whatever
speaks more volume than the money or
financial backing.
It's it's the effort of support.
It's the the idea of being present.